[Música]
los quiero invitar primero a poner
atención a esta imagen esta imagen
es una persona que vino a cambiar mi
vida la de nuestra familia y nos
revolucionó del cielo a la tierra y
también hoy día está cambiando a toda
una generación que viene a revolucionar
el mundo cuando con esta pequeña persona
empezamos un camino incierto
los expertos en ese minuto me decían
pero si tú eres solo una mamá más que
vas a saber tú de todo esto y un ese
minuto lo tomaba como una ofensa
entendiendo que expertos psicólogos
pediatras endocrinólogos y algunos
cirujanos también
tenían que saber más que yo
sin embargo abrí mi corazón mi mente mis
sentidos y empecé a tratar de entender
que era lo que estaba pasando de eso ya
hace cinco años desde entonces entendí
que era una mamá más pero una mamá
distinta una que tuvo que desconstruir
se para volver a construirse desde el
conocimiento y entender que en este caso
y en la mayoría de los casos el amor de
mamá no basta porque no fue suficiente
tuve que empezar a leer a reconocer a
investigar a tener conversaciones a ir a
exposiciones a través de lecturas casi
nada cotidianas porque nunca me las
habían enseñado aprendí que no se nace
mujer sino que más bien se llega a
hacerlo
y luego me di cuenta que también a
través de estas lecturas y que la
genitalidad y el sexo biológico no
tenían nada que ver con nuestra
identidad
eso junto a conversaciones interesantes
y reflexión
tener con claudia rodríguez una travesti
vieja como ella se hace llamar y hasta
con la daniela vega que por ahí se fue a
ganar un oscar
y hoy día un niño de 11 años en un
colegio de la comuna de maipú me dijo
pero porque me habla de esto si esto es
retrógrado
si el género es una construcción social
esto no este llamado hijo
sin embargo esta guagua que no era igual
a mis otros tres tesoros porque yo tengo
cuatro ejes todos los tesoros para mí
como para todas las mamás era distinta
era una guagua que tenía
y que nosotros no sabíamos entender
marcada tendencia femenina de mi hija
era un problema
y entonces díaz y le dije lo grande que
quieres ser mujer mamá yo cuando grande
voy a ser mujer
esas respuestas nos dejaban sin saber
qué hacer
porque no correspondía
entonces la gente me decía a ponerlo al
jardín ahí se va a ser hombre
yo creo que se le va a quitar una etapa
que va a saber una niña de 3 años si los
niños no saben
fue difícil la puse al jardín peor error
porque ahí sí empezaron nuestros
problemas porque esta niña no entendía
que ella tenía que usar cotton a que
ella tenía que ser ruda fuerte
a delicada que no podía quedarse con los
ponis de las compañeras ni menos aún
traerse las muñecas de las compañeras
para la casa lo corto nos invitaron a
irnos del jardín
veníamos saliendo del jardín con mi hija
y me mira y me dice mamá y si mejor me
quedo hombre para que se terminen todos
nuestros problemas
y entonces yo dije hay que buscar ayuda
dónde voy a buscar ayuda con una niña de
este porte que no entiende por qué no
puede ser princesa
efe el psicólogo 67 psicólogos
con respuestas muy variadas algunos me
decían yo creo que se va a tener que ir
del país como si fuera fácil
yo creo que mejor enseñemos la jugar
fútbol porque ahí se va masculinizar
fue un camino complejo y solitario
y otra genial idea pongámoslo al colegio
porque hay entender cuál es su luz el
colegio sin embargo resultó ser aún más
violento y cosas que
ya eran un sufrimiento constante la fila
de los niños y la fila de las niñas
poder nos para niños y los cuadernos
para niños hasta las mochilas era para
niños y para niñas
y ella me decía mamá cuando me vas a
comprar la falda porque yo tengo que ir
con buzos y todas las niñas venir con
falda
y ahí me di cuenta que en realidad no
era que yo la tenía que perdonar de nada
el real problema que teníamos hasta ese
minuto es que yo no le creí a mi hija
yo no creí en ella no creí que ella
tuviera la razón y también me di cuenta
de otra cosa me di cuenta que el colegio
era un espacio violento era un espacio
en el cual mi hija lo había pasado muy
mal hoy día la selena va a un colegio
nuestros caminos sean un poco
distanciado en la lucha ella es
activista desde su propia trinchera día
a día de la lucha tratando de entrar a
un sistema educativo que la invisibiliza
constantemente mi hija no existe en los
libros escolares no es parte del
currículum no es parte de la historia
pero separamos nuestros caminos porque
yo entendí que ese era su misión no era
yo era ella
y empecé un camino distinto que
significaba crear un colegio para niños
y niñas transgéneros el primero en
latinoamérica y en chile
este colegio
partió el 6 de abril del 2018 con cinco
niñas trans hoy día tenemos 18 niñas es
un colegio de nosotros nos ocupamos de
las emociones las sensaciones y el ser
de las personas porque me di cuenta que
en realidad aprender a leer ya escribir
lo vamos a lograr en cualquier minuto
pero aprender a hacer personas personas
empáticas capaces de vivir en comunidad
con esfuerzos colectivos con respeto y
con inclusión solamente se aprende una
vez en la vida
en nuestro colegio las niñez trabajan
desde sus propias construcciones para
nosotros el nombre no es tema
el pelo no es tema sino que lo
importante es que ellos y ellas
sin embargo esta escuelita que no va la
selena a esa escuela porque mucha gente
me dice a tú lo hiciste un colegio a tu
hija no
yo hice un colegio para los niños y las
niñas transgéneros vulnerables de este
país porque no es lo mismo ser
transgénero en el sagrado corazón de
manquehue que en el colegio 241 de la
pintana es bien distinto
nuestros niños se construyen a pulso
ellos son los que valen no se aprenden a
leer oa escribir y les damos el tiempo
de que estos procesos de transición sean
personales no es una burbuja como nos
han querido decir tampoco de su nieto no
los estamos sacando de los espacios
tradicionales para encerrarlos en un
lugar donde los protegemos al contrario
la escuela amaranta gómez de fundación
selena es un espacio que les entrega
herramientas les entrega conocimientos y
les entregas fuerzas para que cuando
ellos salgan al mundo no tengan que
seguir dando explicaciones de quiénes
son y les da la oportunidad de poder
estar tranquilos y tranquilas durante 5
horas al día
porque ser trans en este país primero
significa demostrarle a tu mamá quién tú
eres luego a tu familia quién tú eres y
luego al mundo quién tú eres
yo los quiero invitar
después de esta charla a abrir sus
mentes sus corazones sus sensaciones a
respetar al otro y a la otra
pero en ese respeto hacia las personas
también incluir a los niños ya las niñas
porque los niños y las niñas también son
sujetos de derecho este país es el peor
país del mundo para ser niño porque en
este país los niños mueren a manos del
estado por lo tanto tenemos que hacer
algo yo renuncié a mi trabajo para hacer
algo porque no podemos seguir posteando
en facebook que quisiéramos un mundo
mejor para nuestros hijos y hijas porque
esos niños que hoy día lo están pasando
mal van a compartir con los hijos de
ustedes
por lo tanto no se involucra por lo
tanto tenemos que hacernos cargo
para mí fue un proceso no fue fácil
fueron cinco años de reconstruir me y
todavía estoy aprendiendo y a veces creo
que aún no sé nada a los cuatro años la
selena me dijo mamá me perdonas por ser
niña me costó entender el mensaje pero
hoy día les pregunto a todos ustedes
están dispuestos ustedes a perdonar las
gracias
[Aplausos]